the three
pops
it's becoming more and more important
for us to both recognize
that truth is a pathless
land and it's already
this ineffable perfect freedom
already and
simultaneously to have a power law
of the most common
archetypal both
expansions and dissolvings
for awakening
in other words what are the most
common narratives
of people expanding beyond their
personhood
as well as dissolving themselves
so another way to say that is what are
the most common ways people
experience the impersonal
the infinitude as well as the
absolute nothingness
and this is going to be mission critical
in
the planetary awakening this creation
awakening
is to have this
simple archetypal
representations
of awakening the 2020s is about to be
even noisier than the 2010s was
there's more and more
traffic online and there's
also more and more
signal being put online and the key
is to parse for the signal
and then to distill it
so you have to identify
signal across the core
disciplines and find that metaphysical
truth and then be able to
distill it
down in to the masses
both as explained like i'm five and also
as symbols and maps
and so let's go through this
the three pops as
a map and using these common archetypal
experiences and you'll notice that a lot
of the other content on the channel with
the direct
path series and all of the recent
interviews and content
have really been the continuation of
just
the direct pointing to the ineffable and
the direct
experiential strategies to get to the
ineffable that you already are
basically to help you walk through the
gateless gate to realize
the diamond that's already around your
neck
alright let's start with
why they're called pops we touched on
this a little bit
when we explained there's these
expansions towards infinitude
as well as these very dissolutions to
nothingness
so that's why there are these pops
they're like
micro satoris mini satori
macro satori and there's
this big spectrum
within this awakening
and so let's start with
the person popping to awareness
so this is called a pop especially
because the person
is like a bubble it's got
a bubble around its head
it's like the old aphorism
that goes you are the fish
asking where the ocean is
[ __ ] you're in the ocean
but the thing is is that the human
seeks for the ocean
and in doing so they actually recognize
the metaphysical truth of infinitude and
nothingness
and how they are an appearance
in that process
it's very important because it dissolves
their ego and their contracted identity
and it turns them into a steward and a
shepherd of the creation
whereas for example if they never get
the direct experiential truth
what will happen is somebody will tell
the fish
you're already in the ocean and then the
fish will go on
parroting i'm already in the ocean i'm
already in the ocean
and they'll have never dissolved their
egoic contracted identity
so in order to pop this person
bubble
you really have to do things
that are both simple and that are
a little bit esoteric so let's start
with the simple
the most simple way to pop the person
bubble
is to recognize that you're in the ocean
and in order to recognize you're in the
ocean you just have to do some simple
scientific analysis
where is the boundary between you and
the oxygen that you
inhale just try right now to find it
so where was the boundary
how about the water
so where was the boundary
how about the 1000
species of bacteria in your gut
that each have 2 000 genetic expressions
2 million total genetic expression
100 times more than human genetic
expression
your 20 000 human genetic expression
so how about that boundary between you
and the 1 000 species
of bacteria in your gut how about that
start with the science and pop the
bubble
there's no boundary between you and the
air there's no boundary between you and
the water
there's no boundary between you and the
gut bacteria
you can use science to become more
impersonal
okay so now what's happening is you're
becoming
slowly more and more melted
into the ocean and you're
becoming aware that there's something
metaphysically
true that you've been ignoring your
whole life because you've been stuck in
the contracted person
identity so what we're doing as we pop
this person bubble
is we're using science to understand the
porosity
so
another way to look at that would be
like this
the person
has a box around their head
this is the egoic separation
the whole creationary game is about
identity
if you are the one infinite creator
itself
and everything is one intelligence at
play with itself you win the game
you purify yourself and become in
service to other people
and you get rid of your conditioning of
personhood and you win the game
it's all about identity so here is the
contracted person identity that
is arrogant and saying that they're
separate from all of creation
so i am an arrogant person who thinks
that i'm
separate from all of creation that even
though i'm inhaling this oxygen drinking
this water and have these thousand
species of gut bacteria inside of me
that even though all of those things are
true that
i'm still separate from all of them
humble yourself [ __ ]
that's this shift that's when you go
okay there's no clear boundary or line
between me and between the air i breathe
the water i drink the
thousand species of gut bacteria inside
of me
and so what's happening is you're
becoming more subtle
and when you become more subtle it
enables you to
understand the subject
you have to become subtle to understand
the subject
you will never understand the subject
if you are overly identified with
objects and physicalism you'll never
find the subject
it's the most hilarious thing
it's like the sioux legend that says
hide it inside will never look there
hide it inside will never look there
the [ __ ] source is in your pupil
it's literally there if you just become
aware of the subject of the observer
here's another way as you become more
and more subtle what you can do is you
can start doing
practices like going to
a mirror and holding your eyes open like
this
and looking at yourself in the mirror
and slowly becoming more and more aware
that you have
eyeballs and those very eyeballs are the
size of ping-pong balls
and you become more and more aware of
the very ping-pong
balls that are located right here that
you are
using to know the very power to know you
overlook like nothing for example
when you dream at night and you simulate
out
the reality you have to simulate out the
observer
you have to have the observer you have
to have the witness you have to have the
awareness
to experience the reality
and there's no boundary between the
awareness the observer the experiencer
and the reality
it's all just one
the same thing is true about this
first of all there is no physicalism
there is only what appears to awareness
which is what appears to source
that's all that exists the physicalism
doesn't exist
now the physicalism is
important for us to have the incredible
technologies and engineering and
sciences that we have today
it's very important but we have to be
metaphysically accurate and understand
that the only thing that's
real and permanent is the source
that comprehends the infinite creation
the infinite creation is all transient
the physicalism itself is transient
so your most true nature is the very
source
in which everything arises and passes
the very birth of infinite possibility
and experiencing
so as you become more subtle
you become more aware of awareness
you become more aware that the subject
is paramount you have to have a [ __ ]
subject
you have to have awareness you have to
have witnessing
observation you have to have it this
does not exist without awareness it does
not
exist without awareness
the faster that you can get over that
leap
the faster you'll awaken
shift yourself to the
interior the whole game is
interior the game is 100
interior it's a hundred percent inward
the whole game
the whole game is 100 inward
and it's so funny because it's exactly
where we hide
our very source is
in our pupil and it is the most hidden
from us
it's hilarious
it's so funny okay so you become more
and more aware of awareness aware of the
subject
so you move away from physicalism and
you move away
from objects and you become more and
more
aware of awareness of the
formless of the subject so you move away
from
form towards the formless so another way
to say that is
you become aware of the screen
so before you were only aware
of the modulations
so another way to say that is
before
you were only aware of the coloration
on the paper you were never aware of the
paper blank
pure bear empty
so this is awareness and this is your
personhood
you have to shift from personhood which
is all of your identity
all of your my career
my family my religion
my geography my country
what i think is good what i think is bad
pleasure
pain you have to move away from
all objects perceptions sensations
emotions and thoughts these are the
clouds
that appear and disappear
within the awareness
the pure bear empty blank awareness so
the same analogy that you can use
with paper is the same analogy that you
can use with a [ __ ] canvas
guys this [ __ ] is so easy
just become more subtle and recognize it
spend your time on recognizing it the
more you earnestly dedicate yourself to
metaphysical truth the faster you'll
pierce the veilless veil and [ __ ]
commune with god that is already inside
your heart
you're just being a [ __ ] ass about it
because you spend
vast majority of your time not going
inward
because you spend more of your time on
nonsensical material [ __ ]
like trying to find peace and happiness
in relationships and experiences
and substances and going out to bars and
clubs
and sporting events and traveling and
all of this
other nonsense
you have to dedicate yourself to
metaphysical truth pierce the veilless
veil and [ __ ] unite with the kingdom
of god within you
we'll keep going on simplifying
this look it is a blank
canvas this is the pure bear empty
awareness now how many different ways
can you color this blank canvas
with illustrations you will never come
to the end
you will eternally be creating
beautiful illustrations on this
that is the nature
same thing you're using the device right
now to watch this
all you have to do is pause the video
right now
turn off the monitor screen
and just look at it look at it notice
how it's
blank and empty the monitor
it's blank pure empty there's no
modulation of apps or messages
that's all you have to do
is recognize the difference between when
it's pure bare and empty
versus when it gets modulated
and if you notice on my screen the
background wallpaper is different than
on your screen
that's the point this
expression of source is
getting a modulation that looks like
this
whereas your expression of source is
getting
your background wallpaper
modulation experience but what is the
same
is the screen itself
it's so easy but it's
subtle and if you spend all of your life
in physicalism
you will not come to this subtlety
unless you train
what you've atrophied you've atrophied
your ability
to sensitively sense
the subtle it requires high sensitivity
you have to become aware of the screen
on which all of the modulations happen
of thoughts experiences emotions
sensations perceptions
objects emotions beliefs those are all
clouds appearing and disappearing in the
sky
the sky is awareness
just like the screen just like the
canvas just like the sheet of paper
so you become awareness you become
subtle and formless so
watch the way that
i experience
now is from a place of source
i am the source of awareness
and reality
i know my nature as that i
am the very unmanifested that manifests
infinite creation and that
explores it
and so the way that i identify
myself now is
when you get to this stage it becomes
more
formless more subject-oriented it's
almost like
you are you're just
pure
formlessness is the only way to explain
it it's just
pure formlessness pure being
pure awareness it's not even
a body
so you make the shift from person to
awareness and that's this big pop it's
like becoming aware that you've
always had the power to know but that
you never really
knew that you had the power you were
never
conscious of how [ __ ] important
awareness is
that's a good way to put it you
never were fully conscious
of how important awareness was
another way to say it is you were always
overlooking the power to know
you are always overlooking the power to
know
you are always overlooking the power to
know you are always
overlooking the observer
you're always overlooking the observer
that's the whole point of our creation
is
we purposely create realities in a way
where we overlook the observer
because then it creates the entire
playful dynamic
of forgetting and then turning inward
and remembering
the game is not fun if you're born and
you just
automatically remember off the bat
you have to undergo this process of
wondering
what the [ __ ] who am i why am i here
uh what am i supposed to do and then
when you turn inward finally after
enough suffering
you'll become aware of yourself as the
very
inexhaustible source of infinite
creation
and you'll become aware that the very
observer you were overlooking the whole
time
you are god you're just overlooking the
fact that you are god
because you've attached yourself to all
of what you are
you've attached yourself to your career
and your name and your parents
and your family and your relationships
and your career
and your religion and your geography and
where you live and your country and your
flag and
all of the stuff and it's baggage
baggage baggage baggage baggage you're
like
carrying 17 briefcases
on top of you all the time and you don't
even know that you are the power to know
you don't even know that you are you
only know what
you are the very fact that you are
i am that i am the very fact
that you are is god the very fact that
you exist your very beingness
your very is-ness your very i am
your very awareness itself the observer
itself is
god okay
so this is a huge
monumental pop huge once you get to this
pop
most people stop they basically
they dig
inward and they hit this first bit of
water
and they feel like that's it that's the
ocean i'm there
and in many ways it
is both awesome that the pop to
awareness happened
but it's also limiting because for
example what happened to me in december
was i thought that that was what
everyone was talking about
in december of 2020
now it is what a lot of people are
talking about with awakening
but it's by no means understanding
infinity
and it's by no means understanding void
let alone is it by any means even
understanding the impersonal awareness
you're not guaranteed to jump from
awareness to impersonal awareness
you're not guaranteed just because you
become aware of your
own beingness or your own awareness it
does not mean that you will become aware
that your awareness is
shared among everybody
so this is the second pop the second
pop is to go from awareness to
impersonal
awareness so even if you've become
aware of yourself as the subject and
you've taken
all of this effort to be like who am i
who am i who is the seer who is the seer
who is the observer who is the observer
am i overly attached to all of my
identity what if i was identity
less what if i was just the subject
without
any identity boom that's it
that's the pop i am the subject without
any identity
boom that's god you win the game
perfect so you have to make that pop
first who is the subject without any
identity
damn i love that one
so you got to understand that to get to
the subject with no identity
you have to dissolve all of your
attachments and 17 briefcases full of
baggage
once you dissolve all that you become
aware
of the subject itself
now you can become aware of the subject
itself and then fight off all of your
baggage
as it comes up which is great that's
another great way to do it
it's actually probably an even more
accelerated way to do it
to just jump straight to god realization
and then fight off the conditioned
person baggage as it arises
but we also want to let you know that if
you consciously
remove these briefcases because it's
literally just your decision
to just [ __ ] drop the mass of 17
briefcases of baggage and once you drop
it what you're left with is that your
god
so that's the
no identity that is just god the very
fact that you are the awareness
and then what happens is if you re once
you realize that you realize that okay
well that means that everyone
is the subject everyone is the subject
everyone is the identity-less
the subject with no identity
and then we add all of the identity
then you have all of these different
names look at all these eight billion
different names these eight billion
different costumes
these eight billion different belief
systems these eight billion
different familial and career
structures and geographical locations
and blah blah blah you'll never come to
the
end of combinatorics of identity
that's the point of the game you'll
never come to the end of all the
possibilities of all the combinations
just think about it logically how many
different names are possible
endless how many different ways to
modulate a screen and list how many
different ways to put musical notes in a
song
endless how many different ways to paint
a blank canvas endless how many
different ways to put
food into recipes endless how many
different ways to create
creations of rocks orbiting stars with
civilizations on them
endless so then you begin to understand
eternity
and infinity and so that's why you need
this impersonal awareness you need
god which is this impersonal awareness
to be the observer you can also call
this
the god self the one god self capital s
that's what people say self realization
with a capital
s they're talking about the capital s
god self they're talking about
not your small s lower case
person self
and so this is a pop
to impersonal awareness that begins to
at least hold two perspectives at the
same time
so you talking to your mom or talking to
your brother
talking to your friend or your co-worker
someone online
what you do is you become more and more
aware that it's the same
one awareness talking to itself
so you become aware that it's god
talking to itself
it's the creation talking to itself
now making this transition
is also
much more expansive so even if you pop
this is a little bit this can be a
little bit less subtle
it is subtle but it's not as
big of a pop as this from person to
awareness
is a huge pop from awareness to
impersonal awareness
is a it's a pop but it's not as big of a
pop
and it's usually easier to guide people
from awareness to impersonal awareness
than it is to guide people from person
to awareness
so what you do when you guide someone
from awareness
and personal awareness is you take them
again
out of their own personal awareness
they're very subject they're very
formless
beingness and you begin helping them
understand that the person that they're
talking to
is the same subject it's the same one
god self talking to itself
interacting and exploring with itself
and a lot of people stop there
a lot of people stop at oh okay cool i'm
talking to myself
capital s
yes but you can go to the place
and should go because you want to go all
the way this is what is meant by dig
all the way to water to the ocean don't
just stop when you hit a little bit of
water
go all the way to the until you hit
water the well the ocean
and so what we want you to do is we want
you to begin
holding the civilizational
awareness
so you have to hold
all 8 billion
perspectives simultaneously that is
what is meant by impersonal awareness
now you can also go beyond this creation
to all creations possible and hold the
awareness
that is happening across all creations
that's
a higher level concept
and experience rather let's stay with
one creation take planet earth
take all eight billion perspectives
hold all of them at the same time and
that is god
that is the local creations god
so that's what we're trying to get you
to do that's what we're trying to get
you to realize is that god
is the subject the observer the seer
the awareness that is looking
through all 8 billion people
your identity is with the person and
what we're asking you to do
is to identify yourself as god
because when you identify yourself as
god the person
dissolves it was an illusion the whole
time
so now you're just god so the person is
like
maya it's like the intoxication the
illusion it dissolves the contracted
identity that is egoic
dissolves the conditioning slowly
dissolves the purification towards god
ramps up and accelerates and we're
asking you
to turn inward and reunite yourself with
the kingdom of god that's within you
and then from there what will happen is
you will
naturally serve your own creation
you will become a steward and a shepherd
for the planetary
awakening
versus as a person you try and extract
peace and happiness everywhere you go
it's greedy it's arrogant you think
you're separate
when there's only one intelligence at
play with itself
so we're asking you to become the
impersonal awareness
and when you become the impersonal
awareness you see that it's all god
interacting with god so
you start seeing that this is all the
subject
the capital s self one god self
with no identity then everything else is
identity when you say
someone's name when you say your
friend's name
when i say sanya
that's adding a layer of identity
to what was god so what was god
is now god plus the layer of identity
which is someone's name
likewise when sonja tells me atlas
she's added with a plus sign
god plus sign atlas
so now you see the difference so if you
strip away
all of the layers of conditioning of
personhood and you get to just the
formless awareness the impersonal
subject itself
that's when
the distance and the difference between
us
is just illusion as it said in the great
sound of awakening
and i've been loving that song so much
we'll definitely play a little bit of it
for you guys
and it's a big shout out to
bentino who
brought it into our lives at the
costa rica retreat
distance and the difference
between us is
just the illusion of
the distance
and the difference
between us is
just illusion
and so that's when you get to this
impersonal awareness it's a pretty big
pop
if you get all the way to holding the
entire civilization's
awareness the great i am now
in order for you to now that's when a
bigger pop happens so because you begin
basically holding the entire
civilization's awareness
and so that's a much bigger pop now
this last pop
and maybe even just before we get to the
last pop i would like to explain
that two things the impersonal awareness
can be thought of
as if you take all of these
screens
and if you do
see if i can get this to work for you
guys
all right so if i switch this to input 5
you should be able to see it
great so that's what
the great i am looks like
so if you basically take all of the
different
screens
and you put them together on one big
jumbotron
so that's what god
sees god sees every single perspective
so
so again it's like taking this
for the screen
of atlas and putting it up next to the
screen of sonya
and putting it up next to the screen of
the viewer and then another viewer
and so you see it's all these screens
stacked up and it's basically become
this big jumbotron with eight billion
perspectives on it
and that's the great i am
so it's kind of like taking eight
billion
video inputs let's say
so these eight billion video inputs are
on god's jumbotron
and that's what you're holding and you
have to understand that
every single one of these pops is gonna
be
a unique taste a unique style of popping
that's what's meant by what that aloo
jude the sufi metaphysic the unity of
all finding
every single one of these expressions
sparks of the infinite is going to have
their own unique style of union of
uniting their turn inward is going to
have a unique
taste for example my pop from personhood
to awareness is going to be different
than
sonya's and so hers is going to taste
differently
and that's the uniqueness to it that's
why we do these creations because every
single time this
gps callback kicks in and we turn inward
there's a unique style of finding
that's so profound and revelatory and
there's also a unique fireworking
the individuated expression
and you'll never come to the end of all
of the fractaling and finding
fractal out find inward and firework
right you'll never come to the end
fractal fine fractal fine fractal fine
fractal find you'll never come to the
end
we talked about that in our episode on
intelligent infinity on our channel you
can go find that fractal and find
it's a good one
so then you ask yourself the question
okay
well what comprehends the jumbotron
so a lot of people stop at the
impersonal awareness they just walk
around and they're like hey
you're the same awareness that i am we
are god you're god i'm god i see it
i get it very very few people around the
planet are in
that stage
but there's more and the more you ask is
are you the very source are you the
emptiness that comprehends
god are you the emptiness that
comprehends the one intelligence at play
with itself
it's the one beyond the oneness
it's what is beyond the one god self
it's the very emptiness the very source
that gives
rise to the one god
self experiencing itself in the creation
and in all possible creations
this is what is meant by the no self as
well
because you become aware
of the no self the emptiness
that gives rise to infinite form
and so the very nature of the self even
the capital s
self is in itself a intoxicative
illusion it's only
the dream at play with itself
so you are what comprehends the dream at
play with itself you're what gives
rise to god in the dream at play with
itself
so you comprehend the dream you give
rise to
as the source give rise to and
comprehend the dream
you give rise to the first attribute of
the all-inclusive awareness
of god experiencing and playing in the
dream
so you see how you even have to jump
from
impersonal awareness itself to what
comprehends
the impersonal awareness
the very most upstream
absolute unmanifested ineffable
perfection freedom
giving rise to
this very divine first attribute of
the all-inclusive awareness itself the
one god
self that observes experiences
explores plays in endless creations of
transience
of impermanence
so this pop is also really really subtle
because you have to understand no
self
not only do you have to understand no
self you also have to
you have to take all of the
all-inclusive awareness
and you have to turn that into something
that you can transcend
there is a impossible to describe
emptiness
and there's not even awareness
there's not even creation
so you can go creation most downstream
infinite transients awareness
the middle much more subtle
already the permanent first attribute
the one god self that witnesses explores
and plays
in all the infinite transients
and then you go to what is most real
to what is most permanent
what gives rise to
awareness itself
what gives rise to the ability to know
the infinite creation
what comprehends
that power to know the very power to
know is being
itself comprehended
that's when you hear
siddhar meshwar maharaj nisargata
maharaj bentino masaro
this very powerful lineage that i
respect tremendously and have learned
so much from that you
are the very source itself
you're the very very ineffable source
itself
the inexhaustible ineffable well
of even the great i am
the power to know and infinite
transients
experiencing your infinite creative
capacity
to play to explore never coming to the
end
but this is all transient it's all
impermanent
what is most permanent is all the way
inward go into your very pupil itself
until you hit the black hole until you
hit
the nothingness in which everything
is comprehended what gives
rise to and disappears into
rise two disappears into rise to
disappears into rise to disappears into
rest who disappears into
everything
sharpie appears disappears
the cup of water appeared for you now
it's gone
phone appeared in source now it's gone
when no one is looking at that phone
it's not
being comprehended
the mystic traditions for the longest
time have been pointing at this
information for
millennia and science is now the johnny
come lately
when you look at things like donald
hoffman and the conscious agent
metaphysics that he's working on
it's very much like did johnny come
lately
but it's really really important for us
to leverage things like
the video game analogy and for us to
leverage things like
the synthesis of what science
graph theory graph dynamics
mathematics logic combinatorics
what they can teach the matrix
so that it can wake up to the spiritual
metaphysical truth
that has been talked about the
nothingness in infinitude that has been
talked about for thousands of years
science can help the matrix wake up to
so it's very important to synthesize
infinity
and infinity to synthesize science with
spirituality
cool so these are the pops
remember that the pops
require integration so remember that
if you're at a place where you've
underwent a process of becoming
more deeply aware of the subject
itself take time
to reflect on the subject so just
literally do nothing sit outside
or sit on your couch and do nothing
nothing but just be
and when you just sit and breathe and
just be
and look at space don't look at an
object but look at the space itself
like nobody pays attention to this
the beautiful space or the silence
between the notes
what will happen is you'll become more
and more aware of the subject because
you'll be focused on the space
and you're going to keep your mind quiet
using the breath
and you'll focus more and more on the
subject itself and on awareness itself
so the point is integrate what you've
learned
spend time integrating what you've
learned and go and surround yourself
with other people that
have awakened to these varying degrees
you putting in your north star position
metaphysical truth and spiritual
awakening
that is the amount of earnestness
depending on it will be the
speed at which you will awaken so if you
have so much earnestness that you put 80
hours a week towards it you can awaken
in
less than a year
but if you want to dedicate one hour a
week to it
good luck you'll be stuck in the matrix
for decades
so your earnestness determines
everything
so surround yourself that's why it's
called satsang
truth community sangha you need
the community of awakened people
in order for you to get the proper
reflections
so that people can properly help you
along your journey
become more and more integrated in your
awakened pops that you're experiencing
and if you are going to use entheogens
which i highly recommend the use of
entheogens
the beautiful divine
tool that unleashes god within
that just do them with a great amount
of intelligent wisdom as you do them
so for example if you've never done
magic mushrooms before
you can do them but just remember you
probably might want to start off
at maybe half a gram you might want to
start off on a micro dose
and you might want to feel the
truth the metaphysical truth that
entheogens reveal to you
in a way where on that half gram you
might only
you know really get in there for maybe
you know really lightly
you'll only get in there really lightly
for maybe like an hour or so
but what will happen is as you do that
you'll follow the path of how you sort
of slowly merge
with life itself that's all that
entheogens are doing is they're just
showing you the path
of merging with life itself you keep
arrogantly thinking that you're separate
from life
you think that you're separate from god
you think you're separate from the one
intelligence
and you think you're going to be able to
extract peace and happiness for yourself
in
experience substances material
possessions relationships
and you never will mycelium magic
mushrooms
teach you the interconnectedness of
everything
the oneness of everything entheogens
teach you that
they obliterate your ego especially at
higher doses
and they merge you they unite you with
the kingdom of god that's already within
you
and so you have to wisely watch your
ascent
into the kingdom that was already
around your neck and that
the fish are already in the ocean
so just do with wisdom
and surround yourself with people that
will help in the process
earnestness is key the three pops
person to awareness awareness becoming
impersonal
and then comprehending god becoming
the very source
giving rise to awareness and realities
the emptiness that comprehends infinity
be the emptiness that comprehends
infinity
notice you haven't seen that angle yet
this one smells good like lime
some of the markers are scented
yep
oh it's a little harder to see than i
thought it would be but
that bottom one says emptiness
comprehending infinity so
the three pops
boom all right
that's a wrap
you can also think about it like
the dance of light on your retina
the very retinal matrix itself
if you really pass time on becoming
aware
of awareness and becoming aware of the
impersonal
awareness and becoming aware of the very
source that is going all the way into
your pupil and becoming aware of that
very dance of light on the retinal
matrix and
all of the infinite possibility of that
dance of light arising and passing
arising and passing or rising and
passing arising and passing rising
passing
then you'll get the understanding of
infinity and you'll get the
understanding of emptiness
just emptiness comprehending infinity
cool
infinite love and adoration thank you
you